when people become numbers and mogs a
place for family reunions
shiv Shankar Jana made his way from
Bihar to bhubaneshwar in udisha state to
find his missing son but he says he
wasn't expecting his search to bring him
here
I told my wife we will not find her son
alive I told my younger son too
but they told me to go look for him
there was a problem in the real line it
was the fault of the station master
the closure for some and an anxious
right for others grief has turned into
anger
Muhammad Shaka and his family have
traveled across states and cities to
find their relatives
I haven't seen such a big accident in my
life this is a case of negligence who is
responsible for this doesn't matter if
it's a junior or senior employee the
point is that they have killed so many
people on two trains there's just chaos
across the country the government's
statements cannot bring back the Dead
since Friday nearly 200 bodies have been
moved to two mogs at this medical
building in bhubaneshwar
more than 40 have been returned to
families but a majority remain here so
the procedure is that when the body
comes here they are doing the collecting
the DNA right and then they are doing
whatever documentation has to be done
basic documentation there are some
embalming process is also going on and
then the person who identifies is handed
over the world
separate bodies still remain
unidentified and authorities hope more
families can make their way here
many of the victims were from
neighboring West Bengal and Bihar they
were traveling to cities in the South
looking for work for families here
there's grief and anger as the demanding
answers and accountability
in bhubaneshwar eastern India